al die sectoren
van de woningmarkt zijn diverse sectoren
je hebt de vrije huursector
je hebt de sociale huursector
de koopsector
die zijn allemaal ontwricht
maar kunt u dan uitleggen hoe u dat dan nu gaat doen
ik mag u niet bezwaar
voor deze manier van 1 probleem benaderen
want je kan wel allemaal gaan sleutelen
en hier dan 1 procentpuntje meer en dan daar 1%
maar als je het onderliggende probleem niet aanpakt
dan GA je het grote
vraagstuk ook nooit in wat betere baan leiden
het probleem van onze woningnood in Nederland is
massale immigratie
die VVD CDA en D66 de afgelopen jaren hebben toegelaten
dat GA je dus nooit oplossen door dan te begeven mensen
1 starterssubsidie of net even dit
natuurlijk is het zo
dat als je nu zou stoppen met immigratie
dan dat je niet
van vandaag op morgen
meteen het woningprobleem hebt opgelost
maar wel tussen nu en 3 jaar
dat dan is dat gewoon weg
want je bouwt ongeveer 100.000 woningen per jaar erbij
we hebben 1 woningtekort van 400.000 woningen
dus in 3 4 jaar HEB je dat opgelost
maar dan moet je dus wel nu het andere immigratiebeleid